well next week is school choice week and
this is really an opportunity for
parents to decide which is the best
school for their child yeah one charter
school that opened this past August
wants to be that choice with a big Focus
not only on education but on social and
emotional learning Sage Collegiate is on
Charleston right near Valley View Joshua
peguero Joins us live at the school
location the school had a temporary
location Josh but now a celebration we
can see it behind you for the permanent
location
yeah that celebration just wrapped up
now for the christening of this new
facility you can see people behind me
there's still work being under
construction but they're currently
taking tours of the facility Sage moved
in less than two minutes two months ago
from a temporary location uh the
school's principal says parents wanted a
new option in this area
65 of the schools in this community are
one and two star schools and so in
talking with families there was a real
interest with in having some public
options here in in these zip codes
Sandra Kenny is the principal she says
Sage's philosophy is preparing students
to attend college their classrooms are
named after colleges and universities
they hope to have 800 students from
kindergarten to eighth grade but right
now it's around 200 from K to the fifth
families deserve options uh I mean for
their children in a public setting 65 of
students at Sage qualify for free or
reduced lunches there are several Clark
County schools in this area including
why Austin Vegas Doris Hancock and Rex
Bell elementary schools yet for Zania
Diaz sages teacher to student ratio
which is 27-1 appealed to her I think
the biggest challenge with schools in
the Las Vegas area is the uh extremely
high teacher turnover
um I think schools are you know they're
overcrowded the teachers are overworked
so they're just it's a revolving dwarf
she says safety concerns played a big
part in her decision to choose Sage for
her fifth grade son I feel like kids
feel safe when they know every single
staff member and when it's a smaller
school I feel like the larger schools in
CCSD there's staff members you've never
seen before
now Sage Collegiate is currently taking
applications but for a study grade
classroom there's currently a waiting
list reporting live on Charleston near
Valley View Joshua 8 News Now